the gift-giving season is here soon to
be followed by the season of gift
returns this year you need to read the
fine print according to a recent survey
6 and 10 retailers have changed their
return policies and that includes online
returns as Nancy Chen reports it could
change not only the way we return but
how we buy
[Music]
with the holiday shopping season
underway tis the season also for
surprises including a Crackdown on
online Returns the cost to return an
item by mail at Zara now 395 for J.Crew
it's 7 50.
and for Dillards that return shipping
cost will set you back almost 10 bucks
they're all part of a growing list of
retailers charging return fees typically
in the range of three to ten dollars to
send back purchases I hate it as someone
who likes to shop and return things
often because sometimes you do have to
try things on regardless Washi shops
almost entirely online and was recently
hit with return fees after ordering
multiple pairs of pants I haven't been
able to find a pair of pants that
actually fits me I needed to try on a
lot of things and for certain stores I
did have to eat that five dollar cost a
fee some experts say Shoppers should get
used to with labor and shipping costs up
and retailers dealing with excess
inventory this year and all those
returns add up according to the National
Retail Federation 102 billion dollars
worth of online orders were returned in
2020 that number more than doubled to
218 billion last year about 40 percent
of our Merchants are charging for
refunds and that's up it's nearly
doubled in the last 12 months Jonathan
Poma is the CEO of loop a company
helping more than 1500 retailers save on
return costs this is actually a big
problem for retailers when you start to
stack these costs free shipping on the
outbound order free shipping on the
return maybe a customer acquisition cost
of 50 bucks and you're out almost twice
the cost of the the return and Poma says
less than half of items returned can be
immediately resold if at all for some
Merchants it can be the difference
between existing in 12 months and no
longer being in business and with as
many as 50 000 brick and mortar stores
projected to close over the next five
years the trend towards return fees
isn't going away anytime soon I think
return fees just help us see a little
bit behind that curtain by making us
pause and think about our purchasing
decisions and whether we are being
wasteful or not turning a page in how we
buy in and return for CBS morning's
Nancy Chen New York
when it comes to avoiding return fees
the simplest solution is to return your
gifts to the store if you don't live
near a store consider joining the store
loyalty programs retailers often waive
those return shipping fees if you do and
finally it might be worth asking
customer service to make an exception
but thank you that can be a little risky
as we all know depending who's on the
other side of the customer service right